Speaker 1: So you've got your cult leader,
which is Trump, and then you've got your
cult members who are the Trumpists who go
to the rallies. There was a rally in Texas
over the weekend. We already look at clips
of Donald Trump speaking. Check out some
of these interviews. One of the funniest
things to me is when someone repeats some
conspiracy theory and they don't even really
understand it. And it's sort of like whatever,
whatever the conspiracy theory is, I
believe it. And here's a guy who says,
listen, they stole it was either 1 million
or 100 million votes in Texas. And of course,
Texas doesn't have a population of 100
million. How could you steal 100 million
votes? Doesn't really matter. Check this out.
Speaker 3: Pelosi said there's good could turn
blue. She said that two years ago.
So they cheat, which Mike Lindell
said there's 100,000,000 million votes stolen.
Speaker 1: Yeah. There there was 100 million or
a million votes stolen in Texas. Now, one of those
numbers is, of course, mathematically impossible,
but it doesn't matter to these people. They
just you know, I hate to do this. I really do,
because sometimes I think adopting the language
of the right doesn't make sense. But they talk
about they love to say that there's leftists
who are and PCs non-player characters. These
are just like the background characters in video
games who just they just repeat stuff. They don't
do anything. They do the same motion and over and
over again, that's what these people I don't know,
Lindell said it was like 100 million votes
were stolen in Texas. Maybe 1 million,
I don't know. But clearly it happened. Here
is a woman who raises mules. Yes, who raises
mules. And she drove 17 hours to the rally.
Speaker 3: Opened the people's eyes to the
corruption in this government. He did more
than any president in the history of this
country. Gunshot By the way, she raises
mule. I raised me. I love the hat. Kicks
my 30th rally. He drove 17 hours.
Speaker 2: 17 hours got here Wednesday.
Speaker 3: I'm from East Tennessee.
Speaker 1: Understand? Another
characteristic, another trait of cults and
cult members who is willing to go the farthest.
Literally and furthest, figuratively. To
please and show devotion to the cult leader.
Here is a guy at the rally explaining
that the biblical principles that Trump
adheres to are why he loves Trump.
Speaker 3: The biblical principles
that Trump embraces is what really what
I really like about him. I've never heard
another president invoke the name of God
and Jesus more than I've heard President
Donald J. Trump. And that's the main thing for
me, is that he's embracing biblical principles
and follow the Bible and you can't go wrong.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Now it is true that Trump
will invoke the Bible frequently. Of course,
he does it only as the most obvious form of of
pandering. And we say, who could possibly fall
for that? Well, that guy fell for it. That guy
fell for it. The leader of Latinos for Trump.
I don't even know if that's real. She says God
sent her to the rally to deliver a very important
message to Donald Trump. Are all of these people
merely mentally ill? No, I don't think so. I
think it's it's radicalized politics in some
cases combined with mental illness. And by the
way, couldn't God deliver the message to Trump
himself? Why didn't he? Did he need this lady?
Speaker 2: The message for Trump. I have a message
from the Lord for him. And I'm need to get that
message to him to tell him that He is to call
this nation to fast, pray and repent, including
himself and all the leaders, even faith leaders,
because God wants His people back and he wants
Trump back. And Trump used to surround himself
with faith leaders and then COVID hit
and he was separated from faith leaders.
Speaker 1: Right. That was the real
tragedy of COVID. Trump was separated
from all of the pastors.
Speaker 2: And, you know,
he thinks he's fighting flesh and he's actually
fighting bigger in a bigger realm that he maybe
doesn't understand or no one has explained
it to him. And I don't know. He's surrounded
around people that just won't let us get
this message to him. But it's important
for the I've been traveling the United
States identifying those leaders that
can be assembled that understand. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Well, she's going to give us
that list and we'll examine how many
of those people should be in prison.
A guy at the rally said that he was in Washington,
DC on January 6th. He knows exactly what Antifa
looks like and it was definitely Antifa.
Speaker 3: What did you see that day? I saw
lots of antifa and I know how to recognize them.
And the crowd that was out on the West Coast,
I was like a big Bernie Man festival person. So
I've seen these Antifa scum. I know what they
look like. I smelled a rat. I didn't get anywhere
close to the Capitol because I was going to wait
and see what it was going to be like. It's also
not forget her. We won't forget Roseanne Boyland.
If I ever have a daughter, I'm going to name her
Roseanne after Roseanne Boyland. And of course,
Roseanne Barr, the other greatest American. Sorry,
Roseanne Barr. Roseanne Barr. All right. That was.
Speaker 1: Okay. You know, it's all
getting kind of a little bit weird.
One guy was asked, What's the thing you love
the most about Trump? Here's his answer.
Speaker 3: What is the one thing
you loved about President Trump
and everything? Like just not caring about what
other people think and getting respect from other
countries. We're not now respected anymore.
Speaker 1: Yeah. The truth is. Respect for the
US was at a historic low under Trump. And these
folks just. They refused to acknowledge that or
they don't care. And then here is January six,
defendant Trent Evans, who was one of the people
in Nancy Pelosi's office. He says he coordinated
with the Trump team to do the national anthem.
Speaker 3: Hearing that you led this effort with
Donald Trump tonight to sing The Star-Spangled
Banner. Talk about. Yeah. We have been pushing
actually came up with this idea on Wednesday
and I started pushing kind of late in the game
here asking we were starting through social media
pushes we reached into the president's camp
everywhere we could. I'm J6 defending myself,
so I reached into the camp everywhere. We could
just see how heroic solidarity with these. Yeah.
Speaker 1: He's aj6 defendant. And of course,
we need to show our solidarity with the rioters.
Why? I don't know, but we need to. These
are these are obviously delusional people,
but these are dangerous people. And it should
not be. I mean, listen, I hate to do something
so crass, but remember with the Manson cult. They
were not just followers. They were activated to
become murderers and the cultists can be
just as or more dangerous than the leader.